in the wake of President trump's release
of a tax reform outline CNN's Sally cone
took to Twitter to explain her take on
the prospective legislation she tweeted
translated Trump's tax plan for ian's a
picture of Trump's tax plan and written
over it in pink penances take dollars
from the people give it to the
super-rich this is not how taxes work
there is a basic inconsistency here for
Cohn she's correct that higher taxes on
a relatively small percentage of the
middle class via reduction of tax
deductions would involve government
taking more money from those affected
but she then suggests that rich
Americans paying less taxes somehow
amounts to reallocation of resources
from middle class to those in the top
tax bracket so in other words taxation
is theft when it's applied to those who
aren't in the top quintile of income
earners but for those rich folks
taxation is an expected tribute to be
paid to the government here is the
question at what income cutoff this
taxation become good Cohen doesn't say
but this is pure illogical class warfare
when told this on Twitter Cohn responded
that she didn't appreciate mansplaining
Shero mansplaining is caring am i right
Sally it's called economics planning and
we wouldn't have to do it if you would
logic understand Cohn also ignores the
fact that the rich pay the overwhelming
majority of net taxes in the United
States according to the Tax Foundation
in 2014 35% of Americans paid no income
tax those earning more than $250,000
paid 55 percent of the entire income tax
burden the top 20% of earners paid 84
percent of all income tax according to
the Tax Policy Center according to the
CBO the Congressional Budget Office
report on distribution of taxes in 2013
the top 1% of household paid 34 percent
of their income to federal taxes the
middle 20 percent pages 12.8% the top
quintile of income household Payton
averaged 50 $7,700 into federal tax
coffers in 2013 when you include any
wealth transfers they were paid by the
federal government the 4th highest
quintile paid 2,600 bucks the middle
quintile paid actually made 78 hundred
dollars from the feds and the second
lowest quintile made $12,000 lowest
quintile made 80 800 bucks bottom line
according to the American Enterprise
Institute the highest income quintile is
financing 96 percent of the entire
system of transfer payments to the
bottom 60% and funding the operation of
the federal government so no the
returned under tax they're paying for
the whole operation we actually have the
most progressive federal tax system
among OECD 24 countries but keep banging
that drum
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
so after that auspicious start we'll
jump right in in just a second talking
about what's going on with Ann Coulter
and the rise of fascism in the United
States I feel like I have a particularly
good window on this since I've actually
been at the center of some of these
campus riot type events but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
lyft so if you are looking for a
ride-sharing app if you are looking for
a way to get from point A to point B in
the safest and cleanest possible fashion
lyft is the app that does it so as I've
said many times on the program before my
wife comes back very often very late at
night from working as a doctor
she is a beautiful young woman and I
would not want a creeper driving her
around that is why she uses lifts lifts
checks you checks the drivers through
this this isn't this long security check
they check the cars all the cars have to
be relatively news here not going to get
some weirdo driving up in a clunker from
1987 some rape van from 1987 you're
going to get that with lyft and they're
the people that I trust to drive my wife
around that of the people that she
trusts to drive her around I use lyft
everywhere and there's a reason for that
it's because they're the best right now
lyft is offering our listeners a special
deal for new users you get three free
rides up to ten bucks each that's a $30
value when you enter promo code
Shapiro's so you download the free lyft
app and make sure you enter that promo
code trip hero in the payment section
and you'll start with three free rides
up to $10 each up to a $30 value again
that's promo code Shapiro's promo code
Shapiro again they are the safest they
are the best they are the cleanest and
you can tip people in the app so they
also have the happiest drivers which
means that you're less likely to get a
ticks off guy who wants to beat you up
because he's angry at the wages that
he's been making so lyft is the best way
to travel make sure that you go to lift
and then use that promo code Shapiro in
the payment section okay so the big
issue of the day obviously is what's
been happening in Berkeley so a couple
of points you made about this right off
the bat
first off and does not have any
obligation to go to Berkeley so if I
were an coulter what I go to Berkeley
maybe I would seriously consider it but
I would also consider the possibility
that I wouldn't actually want to be shot
in the face and that's the problem here
is that you know I've been at the center
of some of these incidents but an Tifa
which is now prominent in Berkeley they
actually engage in physical violence we
had on two guests in the last week
talking about the sort of violence they
engage and we had a base nick bannin we
had on lauren southern talking about the
the violence that is now occurring in
Berkeley with an Tifa at the head of it
that is a different thing
a lot of these students so we have a lot
of students who made trouble when I was
at Cal State Los Angeles there was a
near riot there some people got beat up
in the crowd but it wasn't anything like
what you're saying at Brooklyn with the
blood flowing and people throwing sticks
of dynamite and such into the crowd
that's a new thing and I don't blame Ann
for not wanting to die in the middle of
Berkeley you know I think that there's a
strong case that you should go anyway
with bullhorn but it's it's totally up
to her I'm not going to rip her for that
by the same token I am certainly not
going to rip young America's Foundation
full disclosure I work with them all the
time
I'm not going to rip young America's
Foundation for doing what they're
supposed to do in this situation which
is protect their students it is not
Young America foundations fault that the
that the police are refusing to defend
the free speech rights of people
participating at University of
California Berkeley Yap has legal
liability if you have were to go there
and then some of their students were to
get hurt there's possibility the Yap
gets sued and Yap can't have that
because they are a 501 C 3 organization
they have an obligation to protect their
students EF was not anti the event yep
let's probe the event it was Yap back in
the events all the way down the line
until it made clear the police were
going to let an Tifa run roughshod over
the people who are going to show up I
know that yeah stands by its people
because Yap stood by me when to Paul
threatened to arrest me
yes stood by me when CSULA threatened to
cancel my event we walked right into it
anyway so this idea that's being
promulgated by some sort of anti Yap
folks on Twitter that Yap is weak on
this stuff it's just not true
yeah filed the lawsuit alongside me
against Cal State LA they filed the
lawsuit alongside Ann Coulter against
the University of Berkeley system the
idea that they have some sort of
obligation to push their students to go
to an event where the students are going
to get hurt that seems to me foolish if
the students want to go the students are
free to go they're adults but you know
putting it on the a facility there's
really only one group to blame here two
groups to one and FIFA obviously because
they are fascists and their fascist to
engage in violence for political reasons
but the bigger problem here is bigger
than an Tifa it's a bigger problem than
antigua in the 1960s when rioters
basically took over University of
California at Berkeley
the governor was Ronald Reagan and
Ronald Reagan sent in the National Guard
he called in the National Guard and they
literally marched into Berkeley took
over the place and tamp down whatever
violence is taking place they kicked
people out of the public buildings they
had occupied
where the hell is Jerry Brown the
governor of the state of California
what is the mayor of Berkeley doing and
the answer is that they are all standing
by and letting their brown shoots brown
shirts do the work this is a common
thing in fascist in fascist tyrannies
you let the the sort of wild men go and
do the vile and stuff and then you have
your police standby I mean not to the
comparison is not full but it is just a
demonstration of how fascism works
during Kristallnacht
in Germany it was not actually the
police forces overall that we're going
out and burning down synagogues and
beating up Jews for the most part it was
members of the brown shirts which is
sort of paramilitary organization who
are going around doing all this stuff
and the police were told to back off and
let it happen this is what fascist
dictatorships do they don't want to have
all of the violence on their own head
they don't want to be blamed for all the
violence so instead what they do is they
activate people like aunt Eva they like
they let aunt Eva go out there and burn
things and threaten people and hit
people with sticks and clubbed people
and stab people and throw dynamite at
people and then they tell the cops back
off and let them do it okay that is just
as fascist as the fascist who are
actually participating in this nonsense
and it is really quite frightening it's
very frightening it's very scary and it
is totally inappropriate obviously and
it is violative of the First Amendment
again this idea that Berkeley is putting
out there that we can't guarantee safety
let me ask a question if Donaghy C codes
this left-wing radical who's become a
public intellectual on the Left if
Donaghy C codes were to speak at
Berkeley and a bunch of white
supremacists were to show up you know
that the Fantom Trump supporters who are
all the neo-nazi Trump supporters the
media worries about supposedly and let's
say they were all to show up at once and
they were going to protest on ahiki coat
in a violent way do you think Berkeley
would tell the cops to stand down or do
you think they'd tell them to charge in
their batons waving and do you think the
Jerry Brown would call out the National
Guard
obviously Jerry Brown would call out the
National Guard of course he would but
that's not what the University is doing
instead the University says quote this
University's Nicholas Dirk's who's the
university's Chancellor he says this
university has two non-negotiable
commitments one to free speech the other
to the safety of our campus community
members their guests and the public in
that context we cannot ignore or deny
what is a new reality groups and
individuals from the extreme ends of the
political spectrum have made it clear
their readiness and intention to utilize
violent tactics in support or in protest
of certain speakers at UC Berkeley we
cannot wish away or pretend these
threats do
not exist okay no one is saying we
should wish you a pretend threats don't
exist we're saying you should counselor
as a threat that is your job you're the
university chancellor you have a UC PD I
know I went to UCLA you have a UCPD use
the UCPD coordinate with the Berkeley
police the cops who are there I
guarantee you are not sympathetic to
Manteca they're not sitting there going
oh well I'm just going to sit here and
let Antipa do what they're doing this is
a political move by people at the top to
allow all of this crap to happen and
this has become a trend across the
country in violent situations and non
violent situations at Middlebury College
not one student not one has been
suspended or expelled for physically
assaulting a professor left doing
professor runs it up with concussion not
one when I was a University of Wisconsin
a bunch of protesters took over the
front of the state nonviolent protesters
I thought it was ridiculous and funny
but they held up the entire thing for
like 20 minutes
and I said to the cops why don't you
just move them out they don't have a
right to do this why don't you just move
them on out and they said well we've
been told by the administration that if
we move these people out we will also
have to shut down the event in other
words it is up to the protesters to be
nice people and if they're not nice
people the cops won't do anything about
it
this has become common across the
country university administrators who
are too cowardly who are too pathetic
who are too fascistic to shut down
people who want to destroy free speech
and is not equivalent when you say
protestor doesn't have the right to shut
down a full free speech event that is
not the equivalent of shutting down a
free speech event these two things are
not equal when I say a protestor who
tries to take over an event assault
people prevent people from hearing
speech that is not the same as the
speaker themselves I'm fine with
protesters who want to protest and not
disturb the event I'm fine with
protestors yelling at me every so often
I don't care that's First Amendment
stuff but when you have people who shut
down events we have people who threaten
violence like antiva it is your
obligation as a police force it is your
obligation as governor of the state of
California or mayor of Berkeley or PD
chief it is your obligation to protect
the liberty of people okay the police
are not just there to protect your life
the police are also there to protect
your liberty and this idea that the
university gets a violent threat and all
the time they're going to shut down the
right again they're just using the
violent protesters as a proxy for they
don't want this event to go forward this
is political bias they should be sued
and they should lose the University said
it was impossible for the police
department
step in and stop violent confrontations
he said this is a university not a
battlefield
well if you wanted to be not a
battlefield then perhaps you should
actually have defense this idea that you
can just declare it's not about you
never seen on a battlefield that's not
what Antipa thinks they've already made
it a battlefield in fact there's a map
going around then antifa has put out a
various sites I guess that Gavin McInnes
and Moore and southern are supposed to
speak in place of an today or tomorrow
and the end the NT four people have put
out like a full military map of the area
it is not up to Berkley whether this
place is a battlefield it is a
battlefield because the antifa has made
it a battlefield if you wanted to be a
free and open place of learning it is
your job with my taxpayer dollars I'm a
California taxpayer it is your job with
my taxpayer dollars to defend freedom
and the fact that they're not doing it
is ridiculous the police chief Andrew
Greenwood he told the Berkeley City
Council I believe that's the same City
Council that voted to impeach Donald
Trump because this is how crazy they are
he said intervention requires a major
commitment of resources a significant
use of force and carries with it the
strong likelihood of the harm of harming
those who are not committing a crime why
does it carry with it a strong
likelihood of harming those who are now
committing a crime why I hope that it
requires a major commitment of resources
in a significant use of force I hope you
cooperate leniency for people who are
actual fascists who are participating in
violence police have an obligation to
maintain law and order and we've seen
all over the United States that left
wingers do not care about violence so
long as it spring from the left we saw
the mayor of Baltimore say that she
wanted to provide safe spaces for people
to riot in Baltimore they're burning
down businesses and she was talking
about safe spaces you never see the same
thing at Berkeley have you ever seen
have you ever said not in my lifetime at
least have you ever seen a right-wing
mayor say that he's fine with violence
in the streets so long as it promotes
violent causes have you seen that I
haven't seen that certainly not in
modern history and yet the left is doing
this on a routine basis the left is
doing it over and over and over again
this is an assault on free speech and
everybody right left and center should
be calling it an assault on free speech
it doesn't matter what you think of Ann
Coulter that's completely irrelevant but
according to the left all that matters
is that they don't like ankle there so
Bob Beckel the living troll on Fox News
is the five he came out and he was
ripping on Ann Coulter as those
Coulter's Falls and all this was
happening why can't the university
protect
Coulter Minh to have the money they have
the manpower why can't they do it Bob
well first of all let me let me just say
how disappointed I am and all of you
suggesting that this is something to do
with the Democrats and liberals these
are anarchists are coming in from around
the country who have nothing to do with
a Democratic Party Howard Dean is an
anarchist in himself oh really
yeah you know ever head of the
Democratic I know I know that's it was a
short-lived situation I Badgers I love
that the reason I'm for in Colton
speaking and she has a right to speak
number one and every time she opens her
mouth I'll buy it drives away more
people she's becoming more more
irrelevant so she does something like
this to get a lot of attention this is a
woman who said America is been graced by
a Christian God that Donald Trump is
president that wasn't all she could
Marco Rubio a rapist and trays every
Wankel is standing up for Coulter's
right to speak there are people on the
Left who haven't been the ACLU is even
standing up her right to speak but the
people in power aren't and that's the
only thing that matters
so I guess good for Bob Beckel in one
sense but it is just ridiculous it is
ridiculous that so many members of the
of the administration the mayor of
Berkeley that they are going to allow
this to to go ahead it's really
disgusting
apparently Berkeley's mayor has he
called out I love this he called out an
Coulter for soaking possible violence so
Mayor Jesse Aaron Gwin and AHA pronounce
names at Berkeley's about the expressed
change of ideas but that's not what's
happening so I think going forward we
are going to need to have a more visible
police president's presence of these
incidents and intervene it you think you
think you idiot but he blamed the EM
Coulter for all of this he said that
it's an Coulter and Milo who are causing
this again this is the same argument as
her skirt was short therefore she was
asking to be raped it's the exact same
argument and it is truly disgusting and
it's better come under control or people
are going to pay the prices and a lot of
people are going to get killed and I
hope it's not maybe because I'm the one
speaking in campus more often than not
so it's really disturbing me personally
now before I go on on this I want to
talk about ESPN I'm going to talk about
Obamacare repeal I want to talk about
taxes and trades and floors a lot to get
to today before we get some mailbag but
before we do that I want to say thank
you to our advertisers over at C SOCOM
se ESO comm so if you are into comedy if
you like comedy then C SOCOM is the
place to do it they have a brand new
show out it's called hidden America
and it's um it's it's a mockumentary
basically Travel Show making fun of
people like Raisa ashlynn on CNN and all
the rest of the the trout Anthony
Bourdain mister travel show where the
places are real but the people are
definitely not they take you on a
comedic journey through America with a
Travel Show parody that has been called
a long way to gut-punch for every
Bourdain addicts which is great cuz I
think Anthony Bourdain is ridiculous and
silly so making fun of him sounds like a
lot of fun they're a bunch of other
shows that they have as well they've a
lot of original shows they have shows
from Dan Harmon who's the guy behind
community which is a really funny show
they have old episodes of all of the all
of the late-night they have the entire
amount of Python catalog they have the
entire forty two seasons of Saturday
Night Live back when it was good even
they have everything it is V place for
comedy see SOCOM they've all the British
comedy they have kids in the hall and
Parks and Rec as I say you can get it
everybody can get it iOS Android Roku
Amazon fire TV Apple TV for just 390 or
for for just 399 a month you can stream
all the comedy that you could possibly
want at sea so calm use that promo code
Ben you get one month for free so you
can try it out see if you like it my
wife and I love it we watch these all
the time see so calm SE eso calm and use
that promo code then again you can see
all of that for just three ninety-nine a
month so you know there are other
streaming services but none of them have
the sort of catalog but see so doesn't
it don't produce the original comedy see
so does so if you are into comedy see so
is the place to be
see SOCOM promo club and SE eso comm
check it out and get one month for free
so before we before we have to go
exclusively to daily wire comm for the
rest of the show I want to talk a little
bit about what's going on at ESPN so
ESPN fired a hundred people yesterday
and there's a lot of big names they
fired yesterday they fired a bunch of
people who I enjoy watching NFL reporter
ed worker was was fired NFL analyst
Trent Dilfer was fired MLB writer Jason
Stark was fired the entire NHL reporting
team was fired and yet and yet total
buffoons like Max Kellerman still on the
air the all the guests from around the
horn still on the air we definitely need
Kevin Blackistone telling us how the
national anthem is a war anthem he
actually said that on around the horn we
still need him to opine on the virtues
of Caitlyn Jenner who hasn't been
athletically relevant for my entire
lifetime but we have to get rid of you
know the actual people who
or sports this is because ESPN has made
a conscious decision it's the same
decision the Democrats made in 2012 that
they are going for a new demographic
that's really what this is about and no
one wants to talk about it I'm going to
tell you the truth about what ESPN is
doing ESPN has made a conscious decision
that they are going to program leftist
politics because they believe that their
growing demographic base the people who
are watching sports more particularly
sports like the NBA are black and
Hispanic and so they think that if they
put on more hosts to our black and
Hispanic and left then they are going to
gain more black and Hispanic viewership
and they don't seem to care that they
are losing alot of viewers who are
conservative in the process this is why
the NHL is going right the overwhelming
majority of people watch the NHL are
white the overwhelming will not the over
the disproportionate percentage of
people who watch the NBA is black
according to the Nielsen statistics and
they've decided the NBA is more
important than the NHL the NBA is a lot
bigger than the NHL but you don't have
that you could do both I mean if you're
a sports Network you just cover the high
light and you tell me what I need to
know in the news that's why I used to
watch SportsCenter because it was clever
and it was witty and because people were
funny is back in the day when Keith
Olbermann didn't feel the need to talk
politics and it was just it was
interesting and fun to watch I used to
get up at 6 o'clock in the morning when
I was a kid to watch SportsCenter every
morning every morning I get up at 6 a.m.
to watch SportsCenter because that's how
much I love the ESPN and that's how much
I loved SportsCenter and they've decided
to absolutely destroy it they decide
it's more important to hire Jamil Hill
and Michael Smith for a million bucks a
year in order to babble about Donald
Trump than it is to actually have
reporters like as I say Jason stock was
a fantastic reporter for Major League
Baseball it's really terrible
ESPN's public editor said that the
network would continue to push politics
they said the desire to throw a boundary
between sports culture and politics is a
fool's errand the volume of non sports
content within ESPN's Empire has
increased significantly in recent years
some of that has been driven by the
athletes ESPN covers who have in recent
years they're going to speak more
forcefully about societal and political
issues you want to know why they're
doing that because ESPN covers them when
they do it so to pretend that it's the
athletes who just suddenly decided to
speak politically is a nonsense athletes
were speaking politically thirty years
ago as this guy rubra as he as he
acknowledges the difference is that ESPN
has now decided to make socially active
athletes the heroes of their little
morality plays and there are those of us
like me who just want to watch it with a
baseball all I want to do is watch MLB
Network now
I'd rather watch MLB Network and watch
Kevin Millar talk about nonsense about
baseball than I which I want to watch
politics I'll watch politics with a lot
of much baseball watch baseball
I don't need your take on Caitlyn
Jenner's heroism and transgenderism in
the Olympics I don't need it
okay and this idea that ESPN is just
going to keep preaching politics good I
hope everyone keeps cutting the cable I
hope that people keep tuning out there
are two ways that ESPN makes money one
ways from cable subscription fees the
other way is from advertising their
ratings have been plummeting they should
plummet people are cutting the cord
because the technology is changing and
no one feels the need to subscribe to
cable anymore
I used to subscribe to cable
specifically for ESPN and I'm going to
unsubscribe from cable this week because
there's nothing for me to watch on ESPN
anymore because I have nothing to watch
on ESPN I'm the day before they cut 100
of these reporters I'm day before they
did that they ran a piece on espn.com
titled five poets on the new feminism on
espn.com you think I want to read five
poets on the new feminism I won't even
read it if it appears at Jezebel I'm not
going to read it if it appears in
everyday feminism and I love everyday
feminism because it's hilarious but I'm
certainly not going to read it if it
appears at espn.com again the left has
infused every aspect of culture with
politics and they shouldn't be surprised
when the backlash is to infuse politics
with culture which is one of the reasons
that Donald Trump is the President of
the United States well I want to talk a
little bit more about all that and then
I want to get to the politics of the day
Obamacare repeal and taxes and trade and
the border I'll get to all of that plus
the mailbag but you have to go over to
Daley wire com for that you can
subscribe for $8 a month over at Daley
wire.com become an annual subscriber and
you get a free copy of Jeremy borings
the arroyo fictional film set on the
southern border action action story a
kind of a newfangled Western set on the
southern border about the property of a
rancher being used as a thoroughfare for
trafficking drugs and human beings it's
basically why we need the Trump wall the
moving so go check out the Arroyo but
you do that by becoming an annual
subscriber over its daily wire or you
can subscribe over at Apple podcasts
iTunes SoundCloud and when you do make
sure you leave us a rating
make sure that you that you leave us a
comment we always appreciate it and we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you